[Música]
y llegó la hora de la información
económica en france 24 por ello me
acompaña en el estudio mi compañero
jorge hurtado jorge bienvenido iniciamos
economía hablando de los precios
mundiales de los alimentos y es que la
organización de las naciones unidas para
la agricultura y la alimentación fao
actualizó el índice de los precios de
los alimentos y aunque bajó levemente en
mayo es decir 0,9 puntos o un 0,6 por
ciento menos respecto a abril todavía
está un 22,8 por ciento por encima que
hace un año ahora si revisamos los sub
índice de este dato los alimentos
encontramos que el índice de precios de
los cereales aumentó un 2,2 por ciento
en mayo con respecto a abril liderado
por los precios del trigo este aumento
en el precio del trigo se debe al
anuncio de india de prohibir las
exportaciones así como por la reducción
de las perspectivas de producción en
ucrania tras la invasión rusa el índice
de precios de la carne también sufrió un
aumento mientras los precios de los
aceites vegetales el de las dietas y el
azúcar registraron algunos descensos un
dato que llama bastante la atención
valentina es que la previsión que hace
la fau de la producción mundial de
cereales
el organismo pronosticó un descenso de
la producción mundial de maíz trigo y
arroz para la cosecha de 2022 2023 con
una producción de 2.784 millones de
toneladas esto representa un descenso de
16 millones de toneladas menos respecto
a su previsión anterior bueno pues
bastante grave estas fluctuaciones en la
producción mundial están vinculadas con
la guerra en ucrania y es que la
invasión rusa en ucrania redujo de forma
drástica las exportaciones de ucrania
que es uno de los mayores productores de
cereales y aceites vegetales del mundo
la guerra afecta a los principales
puertos del mar negro disparando los
precios y llevando a naciones unidas- a
advertir que la escases de alimentos
puede empujar a millones de personas a
emigrar los agricultores ahora enfrentan
elevados costos de la energía y de
insumos y la onu ha dicho que la falta
de fertilizantes podría también agravar
esta crisis alimentaria para el año 2023
hay que recordar que los precios de los
alimentos ya estaban altos desde antes
de la guerra esto por los problemas de
la cadena de suministro y el repunte de
la demanda que trajo consigo la pandemia
el aumento de precios de alimentos
afecta a los países más pobres donde los
comestibles representan básicamente una
gran parte del de todos los consumidores
y a propósito de este tema el presidente
ruso vladimir putin dijo que se intenta
culpar a rusia de los problemas del
mercado mundial de alimentos y negó que
moscú prohíba las exportaciones de grano
desde los puertos ucranianos también
dijo que el problema es por las
sanciones de occidente a su país
escuchamos
por supuesto ahora vemos un intento de
trasladar la responsabilidad de la
situación del mercado mundial de
alimentos y los problemas en ese mercado
a rusia y podemos decir que este intento
como dice nuestra gente es un intento de
pasar de una cabeza enferma a una cabeza
sana los europeos no escucharon nuestras
peticiones urgentes de mantener los
contratos a largo plazo de los envíos de
gas natural y han empezado a cerrar los
algunos contratos siguen funcionando
pero han empezado a cerrarlos y eso tuvo
un impacto negativo en el mercado
energético europeo los precios subieron
rusia no tiene nada que ver con ello y
cuando los precios del gas natural
subieron también lo hicieron los de los
fertilizantes porque algunos
fertilizantes se producen con gas
natural todo está relacionado cuando los
precios de los fertilizantes subieron
muchas empresas incluso en los países
europeos resultaron no ser rentables y
empezaron a cerrar y el volumen de
fertilizantes en el mercado mundial ha
caído bruscamente y los precios subieron
y subieron de forma inesperada para los
políticos europeos se lo hemos advertido
y no tiene nada que ver con la operación
militar especial rusa en bombas
pero lejos de esa discusión política la
idea de una probable crisis de alimentos
está tomando fuerza eso es algo que ya
están adoptando varios líderes mundiales
y también organismos internacionales
recordamos que las exportaciones
ucranianas de grano y semillas
oleaginosas están paralizadas como
consecuencia de esta guerra los precios
del trigo aumentaron más de un 50 por
ciento este año rusia y ucrania
representan el 12 por ciento de las
calorías que se comercializan en el
mundo el secretario general de naciones
unidas antonio guterres advierte que los
próximos meses existen la amenaza de que
el espectro de una escasez mundial de
alimentos que podría durar inclusive
años recordó que hay 250 millones de
personas que están al borde de la
hambruna y si la guerra se prolonga
según el otro cientos de millones
podrían caer en la pobreza
bueno pues cifras bastante críticas por
eso ustedes muchas gracias por esta
ampliación económica que en france 24
[Música]